The first step in your project should
be to think about the database schema.
Remember to write your
create table statements in
a file called tournament.sql.
You'll be submitting this along with
your code as part of your final project.
Remember that after you've created your
database, if you decide you've made
a mistake, you can always drop a table,
or the whole database and recreate it.
And if you need to clear out the data
in a table, you can use delete.
Remember that drop table will
remove the table completely, and
you will have to recreate it
using the recreate table command.
Whereas delete from that table
will just remove the rows leaving
the column definitions,
constraints, and so forth.
Intact.
A few more things to keep in mind.
When players are added to a tournament
the database should assign each
player a unique ID.
You've seen how to do that
using the serial type.
There's an extra credit option,
where you can extend the project
to support multiple tournaments.
If you do that you'll want
unique IDs for those too.
Second, remember that you
can use SQL aggregations,
when you want to count things or
add them up.
If you find yourself pulling lots of
rows from the database into your code,
and then using len to count them,
or using a loop to add them up,
trying doing that in
the database query instead.
Last, if you notice your queries
start to get really complicated,
don't forget about views.
Views work nicely with aggregations,
when you want to present
summary data quickly.
If you use views,
make sure to put your create view
statements into tournament.sql,
along with your create tables.
With that, it's time to get into
designing your database and
writing your code.
On the next page, you'll find a full
description of the project, and
an outline of the functions
you'll be writing.